All right, welcome everybody to another Zoom call.
It is 19th of October, 2022.
Time flies.
Reminder to everybody to check the members' only site for announcements
and that you all have access to all our courses.
Maybe you're the same password as you use to get in the members.
All right, first question.
We are trying out a beaver band.
A beaver band is a PEMF band.
It's a low-gouse PEMF band.
Do you recommend them? Why or why not?
What would be the possible benefits for my husband
who has Parkinson's and myself?
Stage 1 breast cancer, fully removed, known for cancers.
Beamer sends a low intensity pulse electromagnetic field to the body
which enhances blood circulation by 29%.
So yes, PEMF units are great.
PEMF units are fantastic.
They're a great tool to help with everything.
Just be careful with claims.
So this, remember, I said PEMF units are separated into really too,
I think they're multiple different categories.
There's low-gouse PEMF units.
And then there are higher-gouse PEMF units.
And it really has to do a lot with the benefits that you receive.
So low-gouse PEMF units versus high-gouse PEMF units.
The gouse is the output.
So these beaver amats the IMRS.
There's, oh gosh, there's maybe a dozen different brands out there
that are low-gouse PEMF units.
They can be extremely beneficial because they're still putting out this pulse
electromagnetic wave, but it's not even something you really feel
because I think the beaver uses about 700 gouse.
That's the output of it.
Versus like a professional model PEMF, like the pulse brand professional model PEMF
puts out over 30,000 gouse.
That's 700 versus 30,000 is a big difference.
But you really pay for the unit.
The price of the unit is based upon the gouse output.
So $5,000 for a beaver and that's pretty good.
I would check into another brand called the IMRS.
Looks like that.
That's a brand that's not sold through multi-level marketing,
but that's what the beaver is.
And I think they're a little less expensive than that.
And they still put out the same gouse as the beaver.
If you want to go with a higher level gouse, we sell the PEMF
that is a pulse for life brand and it puts out the one that we sell
is 6 to 8,000 gouse, but you pay more for it.
So you'll pay about $8,000.
I think they're $8,000 or $8,000.
So you really get you pay for the gouse output.
But for somebody with cancer or somebody with a serious disease,
you're really almost need a higher gouse output machine.
So the low gouse output machines like the beaver or the IMRS,
they can be good, but part of the struggle that I say,
they're still considered a pulse electromagnetic field machine.
It's just that they're just very low gouse output,
therefore they're a lot cheaper to make.
Therefore they can sell them less expensive,
which I still think they kind of want to price them.
But I'm gouse output, you're getting 700 less than 1,000 gouse.
But then they take the claims of all the research that has been done at PEMF.
And literally there is a slew of research done at PEMF.
But it's all with the high gouse output machines.
And then they're saying, look at this research on PEMF.
It increases the blood micro circulation by 29%.
Well, I'm sorry, but that was research it was done with a high gouse output machine,
not the low gouse output machine.
So they're kind of stealing research done on a very different machine
and then claiming that research on for their machine, which isn't kind of honest.
So I'm not against the beamer.
I mean, there's it's still better.
Having a low gouse output PEMF was better than not having to one at all.
So we have patients that have beamers.
I say, good, use it, use it.
Absolutely.
But if I was going to buy a new one,
I wouldn't buy a low gouse output one.
I'd buy a high gouse output one.
It's high as I could afford.
You know, can't afford a, you know, a professional model pulse brand that puts out 30,000 gouse.
Of course, they're $40,000, but you could afford maybe $9,000.
I don't know.
Maybe not.
So, but look into it.
If you're going to buy a low gouse output one, look into some other brands.
I think they're even cheaper than that.
I husband is almost done with his eight rounds of chemo.
I understand that this is a kill phase.
What is used for kill phase after the chemo?
So everything that we have him on is to help kill the cancer too.
So this is the terminology that your oncologist gave you.
Okay, the kill phase via standards of care would be the chemotherapy or the radiation that they're using.
And then the, you know, the debugging phase would be a surgery.
So this is the, you're, you're utilizing terminology from your, from your oncologist.
So after the chemo, you're doing all sorts of natural things to try to kill the cancer too and try to get your immune system to kill the cancer.
You know, that's why he started with us.
So that's what we're already doing.
So, if your question is what is the kill phase for the standards of care approach?
It would still be radiation. It'd be more chemo.
I am not honestly rarely hear oncologists use this terminology anymore.
So that that's what they'd be using for something that they're giving to kill the cancer.
So this person shared an article from Dr. Judy, Mike events about HIV and retro viruses.
So it was really on retro viruses and an MRA viruses and how absolutely dangerous they are to our body.
So if this is the question, maybe the things in this article are all news.
I know you're familiar with the work of Dr. Judy.
It's a long article, but touches on potential cause of so many things, including cancer, chronic line, et cetera.
I wonder if any of the substances you test for us would be antiretrovirals, as she mentioned, as effective natural treatments.
So effective antiretrovirals, number one category of effective antiretrovirals is to really to stimulate what are called T-reg cells.
So a T-reg cell is an immune cell that calls the immune response.
So what happens with retro viruses and MRA vaccines, like the vaccine that was recently pushed, it is still being pushed,
it stimulates an immune response that could be a hyperimmune response that can really damage cells and could actually lead to an autoimmune disorder where you're making antibodies against self tissue.
So in order to combat that, you want to up-regulate your T-reg cells or also called TH3 cells.
So your T-regular cells are, that's what reg is short for regulation, it regulates your immune system.
So it calls a TH1 response and calls a hyper-TH2 response.
So the benefit of that is during an autoimmune phase or a viral phase, you can be damaging self tissue and by stimulating T-reg cells, you're calming that autoimmune response down.
So what are some natural things that calm that down that are natural T-reg stimulators? Well, vitamin D is probably your most known T-reg stimulator.
But most of your flamminoids that we've spoken about for pain relief that we've spoken about for inflammation can help balance T-regs too because they increase the inflammatory phase of the immune system.
So the inflammate decrease in inflammatory cytokites, most known as interleukin 6, also interleukin 17.
So those are the inflammatory immune responses that you want to calm and your T-reg system will do that.
So what would you use for natural T-regulation? Stimulation, one would be vitamin D, but other would be all your flamminoids, which are the, which are curcumin,
resveratrol, EG-CG, from great T-extract, in your order, corsetin, your stingy dental, things like that that you use to decrease inflammation, also do beneficial.
I have hemorrhoids for years, and they would bleed at times, however I now bleed with almost every bowel movement. I dealt with severe constipation during chemo.
Is it safe to continue doing coffee elements? Well, it's yes and no. So if you're bleeding from the hemorrhoids and you're inserting the tube in your rectum and it's irritating the hemorrhoids that I'd say no.
But if you're saying, well, no, it's not, the tube is not irritating, and that's not the issue that I'd say go ahead, you'll have to kind of discern that for yourself.
But if inserting the tube is what is majorly causing irritation to the hemorrhoids, that's just going to cause further inflammation and make those worse, so no.
Definitely, you want to look at our constipation, know how she also look at that detoxification course here, because the detoxification course, memory of free access, use your username password that you used to get into the membership site.
The detoxification course lays out the seven phases of detoxification and its phase six of detoxification that you want to be aware of phase six has to do with elimination.
So in that course, I lay out things that you want to take to help with elimination to soften your stool, so you're not buried down when you're going to the bathroom, you're not having any constipation issues, and you're keeping very loose stools.
So your main things for that would be what are called phase six assist, which is our private label.
A product that has an allo in it called Cape allo that will really help with constipation probably more than anything else that you've ever taken.
Several other different products depending on what kind of issues you're having and how bad your constipation is.
So look at seven phases of detoxification course, and I think that will be a good help for you right there.
So by that on our website, top of our website, you'll see courses.
I am alternating into a fungal meds that had been sent home with me from the hospital to address a fungal cough so fungal infection in her lungs.
Plus using cortiseps remember I said how cortiseps mushroom is so so good for your lungs alternating olive leaf, which is good for fungus.
I started a difficult and noxophyll wondering if you're able to prescribe at all, looking to get a sporadox prescription.
No, I apologize and I cannot subscribe so looking for a functional medical medicine doctor medical doctor would be best.
There are some naturally minded clinics in Minnesota. I know this person is in Minnesota that I'd recommend so I can email that to you for Minnesota patients.
I have access to supplements one with beta glue can so beta glue can is from mushrooms you get it from other sources too, but it's polysaccharide stimulates your immune system.
And actually the cortiseps has beta glue can get it as well. One with the amino acids to help stop muscle loss should I be adding these to what I'm taking.
Certainly can I don't have this person's protocol in front of me, pretty sure I have another beta glue cans, but they're something wrong.
The beta glue can is probably my favorite supplement of all time so that's why I'm not sure so much.
So they don't have access to oxygen chambers are there other in home less expensive options.
So less expensive options, I don't know. There is a company called oxy health and that is show you the company in just a second.
So oxy health is has a lot of in the whole chamber chambers that are really good.
That's these kind of chambers they look like this they but still you're looking at probably the least expensive would be $15,000.
But I do know that if you do contact oxy health, they have a lease to old option that you could just use as a rental, you could use it for six months and send it back.
So look at oxy health.com and these chambers, I think are the highest quality home chambers. There's some cheaper chambers out there that are cheaper.
They're less expensive, but they're more quality to oxy health is a chamber that will last a lot of time. It's a really good quality chamber.
I'm thinking about using a new supplement called life one ingredients include coconut oil, grape seed oil, chrysan, turkey tail, phosphatidol, coli, molberry, phosphatidol, serine, dim, turmeric, green tea,
rice bran, rice bran would be just a filler corset and already taking a few of these as a redundant.
Yes, no, maybe, I mean lots of times people are asking me to reduce their supplements.
If you're happy taking those and you feel led to that, I feel there's nothing bad in that. Those are all good things.
There you certainly can do that.
Questions from the chat. Is there a high benefit for using the beaver all night long?
You can. So if you have a beaver, again, use it, you know, I don't, you know, just because it's a low-gouse machine doesn't mean it doesn't have value.
If you can set it where you can use it all night long, yes, that'd be great. You're getting that that pulse electromagnetic field in you that's going to help.
So what is it useful to do in 20 minutes session? Yeah, the longer I think you can do it, the better benefit you're going to get off of it.
Could my breast fat volume fill back in after the blacks have is done?
Well, yes, you will heal with fibrous scar tissue and stuff. So yes, that's possible.
Will your breast size be, you know, equal bilaterally? I don't know.
Yeah, that's, you know, how do the people do it that did not fill back?
Maybe the size of their breast makes a big difference too.
Is this be supplement okay for me?
I'd have to look at that. Let me look at that real quick.
The be supreme from designs for health.
The only thing with that is, is that does contain five methyl tetrahedral folate as the folate, which for people without cancer that would be the right type of folate.
It contains methyl comolamine for the B12. Now, understand, I talk a lot about this in the genetics stuff.
But, you know, we need methyl groups. They're essential for us because methyl groups help turn genes off.
That's the main thing that a methyl group does.
And so these supplements, the folate is in the supplement is five methyl tetrahedral folate.
It adds a methyl group. So you get the benefit of the methyl group.
And the B12 is methyl comolamine.
So it's bound to a methyl group problem with methyl groups with somebody who has cancer.
If you get excess methyl groups, you could basically be over-methylating.
And you risk turning genes off that you don't want to turn off.
That is tumor suppressor genes.
So remember in each of your cells, you have tumor suppressor genes.
You've heard probably the most about tumor suppressor genes with the bronca gene.
Now, the bronca gene families has dozens and dozens of different bronca genes.
And they act as tumor suppressor genes. The most research is the TP53 gene.
That's another tumor suppressor gene. There's numerous tumor suppressor genes.
What do tumor suppressor genes do?
So when a cell starts to replicate, to rapidly, i.e. act like a cancer cell,
the tumor suppressor genes are supposed to turn on and stimulate cell death apoptosis.
There's some people with a lot of defects in their tumor suppressor genes can have a reduction of that action taking place.
If I have the bronca gene defect and I have the bronca gene defect,
a defect in the tumor suppressor genes never cause cancer.
But if I have cancer starting to grow by tumor suppressor genes,
if they have a lot of defects in them, will probably not function as well.
And will probably not function as well by turning on cell death pathways.
So if you use a lot of methyl groups, you will also overly turn those genes off.
So I don't like giving cancer patients supplements with methyl groups.
That's why if you have a B12 deficiency, we typically recommend either hydroxylcobolamine or adenosylcobolamine,
not methylcobolamine because methyl groups will help turn off tuber suppressor genes.
And most of our cancer patients are eating real well, are eating more green leafy vegetables than they ever did before on their new diet.
So they're getting plenty of natural methyl groups.
I don't see any reason to be overmethylating this person.
The only time that we would I would override that logic, if this person was pretty much in a very stable state with their cancer,
they're doing really well and we look at their blood work and they have elevated homocysteine.
So elevated homocysteine, you want to use the B vitamins and the methyl groups to help with high homocysteine levels.
So if a person has elevated homocysteine, then I would override that if they're doing well with their cancer.
So I would override that because elevated homocysteine can etch your endothelial cells.
That's the cells that line your arteries and can cause excess plaquine because of that etching.
The cholesterol is trying to repair that etching and could cause heart disease quarter heart blockage.
So you don't want high elevated homocysteine levels.
You need more methyl groups.
The only other caveat to that if the person was doing really well and genetically they had a double allele defect on their two empty hfr genes that I'd say maybe we should add some methyl groups.
But even a cancer patient, if they have a double allele defect on both their empty hfr genes.
And they have cancer that's growing, I still wouldn't give methyl groups.
Any particular reason why my oncologist is ordering a PET scan after my four week chemo holiday versus a CT scan, which I normally used to.
Yes, that because that is standard procedure.
So I can't remember if you received a PET scan before or not, but that's irrelevant typical standard procedure.
Is your once your diagnosed with cancer, they're going to start chemotherapy.
Then typically a month after chemotherapy, you'll receive a PET scan and typically insurance won't cover a PET scan until after chemotherapy.
And the oncologist wants to know if there is metastasis anywhere else.
And if you did receive a PET scan prior to chemotherapy that he can compare if there was metastasis prior to chemotherapy versus post chemotherapy.
So that's the purpose of order in a PET scan.
Again, the value of a PET scan is that you're going to see if there's an increased level of metabolic uptake.
So the glucose from the PET scan in all throughout the entire body versus a CT scan, which is just looking at structure tissue structure in the area of the CT scan in its regional.
So a CT scan is regional, maybe we're going to do it abdominal or upper abdominal CT scan.
And but a PET scan is through your whole body.
I heard the caracology clinic uses off label drugs for use of cancer. Yes, they do.
Caracology protocol uses off label drugs to help block fuel pathways.
So we have a number of patients that are using a portion.
I don't know if I have anybody is using a full caracology protocol right now.
But that's from Dr. Jane McKellen's book about blocking the fuel pathways.
Different cancers using off label drugs that's so caracology is just using her protocols.
We I do have a number of patients that are using several of the off label drugs to block those pathways.
Again, would it be something that I would do? Well, if I wasn't doing well, and I was crashing, yeah, I would give that a try.
If I was stable in doing well, I don't know that I would go that way because those drugs also have, you know, secondary side effects.
So any of the most most drugs have side effects that like use listed in here, docs of cycling, you start taking it in a biotic, you wipe out your floor and your body.
I mean, there's some serious side effects from taking docs cycling on a regular basis.
So just got to weigh those out, you know, if you're doing well, I don't know if I go down that pathway. If I wasn't doing well, then I might, you know,
I'm afraid about choosing that pathway. So back to back to the question about the B supreme vitamins.
So that supplement in particular, if we're choosing to get methyl, if I've approved using methyl groups, that is a good supplement, just by the way.
That is, that is a good supplement. I bought a probiotic not realizing that it contains dairy. Is that okay to take.
Yes, there's not enough dairy in a supplement, even if it was a capsule filled with milk to make a difference in driving the cancer. So don't worry about that.
Well, we put you on a diet to go dairy free, watch you stay dairy free, not for an allergy to KC that you could react to, but because it is an issue with driving your cancer, even when we look at your genetics, because we look at your HLA genes and your genes for dairy and if you have, you know, pretty bad defects of those genes, even if I don't think gluten or dairy is driving your cancer.
I still may suggest that you go off of those things, because, you know, having, you know, double set of double legal defects in your HLA genes, you know, you're probably gluten sensitive and you don't know it, you know, if you're eating gluten.
So maybe it's not driving your cancer, but it's secondarily causing this ramped up inflammation throughout your whole body and could be making it more difficult for your cancer, for you to heal your cancer.
So remember, there's, you know, whole category of food sensitivities that if I am, let's say I have a gluten sensitivity and I keep eating gluten that I don't know I have a gluten sensitivity.
It's going to cause inflammation in my brain, it's going to cause systemic inflammation and it's going to make it more difficult for my immune system to kill cancer.
And if I stayed off a gluten and called that whole inflammatory process down, so you're trying to, you know, attack the situation at multiple levels, it's hard to kill a growing cancer when your body has to deal with, you know, fights at other fronts.
So there is value in doing food sensitivity panel and the only one that I would recommend is Syrex panel.
So Syrex panel is the array 10, or if you want to just check gluten, dairy if the rate 3x and the rate 4, but the rate 10, if you're already gluten dairy 3 and you're staying away from those things because you read enough and you're smart enough.
Which I think everybody should stay gluten 3.
Then getting a Syrex array 10 done, you could order that right to our store.
We said you have to go get a blood draw somewhere, these are blood draw kits. So you have to get a blood draw locally.
And then we get the results and then we'll let you know we'll go over it together, really easy to read.
But I go through the Syrex testing heavily on the Lyme course, and I can actually have a auto immune course that goes over food sensitivity testing and testing for mold and other things, which I think is wise for cancer patients too.
But if you look on the Lyme course, I think it's in module 3 or 4, go over food sensitivity testing and nausea and go over auto immune diseases and food sensitivities with auto immune issues and nausea too.
So there's few fairly technical videos in there that you might have to listen to a couple times, but it really helps explain the whole idea that I'm talking about.
If you have this chronic inflammatory response due to food antigens, even though it might not be a driver to your cancer, it's certainly not helping you heal from serious disease because your immune system is fighting the battle at multiple fronts.
So do consider this at least as a wise choice in some instances.
So your diet is so important where you know college of say diet has nothing to do with cancer.
That's the most idiotic intelligent thing that I can imagine because your diet has to do with so many things, everything, you know what you're consuming, whether it's toxic food or nutrition, your body has to deal with to say that it has nothing versus idiotic.
So, you know, you want to decrease your overall inflammatory response as best you can.
Cyrix testing is the way to go for that.
And I explained it with some of those videos why it's the only lab that I recommend.
You do have a couple other sensitivity labs on our store, but I don't recommend them.
So, they're just less expensive for the average person doesn't have a serious disease. It's fine, but if you want to really get better, you want to do antibody testing that's going to measure foods in cooked and raw situations and measure the peptides, which are the portions of the protein in foods, because that's the most important thing, especially when you look at the cool to the dairy.
Also, the clinics Facebook page has a recent video, I'm sorry, yes, the Facebook page is circulating videos from ever that I've ever done. And, you know, I have, I did all 700 videos out there.
So, I apologize for that, the IVG test is no longer available.
But thank you for telling me that any other questions.
We haven't received the initial genetics test yet. Tell us if we need Cyrix to after that.
The genetics test is going to test for defects that create a suppose a person to dairy and or gluten sensitivity is another gene has been linked to a few other things to, so when we look at the genetics, it doesn't tell us you have food sensitivity just tells us you have a greater chance of having a food sensitivity.
There's food sensitivity really can be completely independent of genetics because the person could have no defects other HLA genes, but have a raging gluten sensitivity because it's not a genetic component, it's really a component of health of the person's gut order.
So, as we've got said, well, they're going to have peptides of gluten, that means portions of the gliad and protein that are going to get across the gut, membrane into the blood and the immune system is going to look at it and feel crazy because it was never supposed to get across it got across because of the damage cut border.
The immune system is going to fire an immune response against it and of course it will never die because it's simply a protein or a portion of the protein follow peptide.
And then your B cells make antibodies against it now you got circulated antibodies against peptides and gluten, so every time you include it, you fire this inflammatory response in the gut in the body everywhere you have this inflammatory response worse with gluten and areas you have gluteomorphine.
In case you have morphine receptors in the brain, so that if you do have an inflammatory response in place you're going to cause inflammation of the brain so it's why I say inflammation of the gut equals inflammation of the brain is very logical and it's chemical so it's proven literally hundreds of research papers.
So while there's value in looking at the HLA genes on your genetics that itself really just gives you clues so if you have defects out there, I will recommend that you go gluten free or dairy free, even though I didn't recommend it to the initial testing.
But that's just what the little piece is really better if you just go gluten free, you know, that would be the smartest thing to do. That's why when I you see a lot more autoimmune patients, I wouldn't really do the Syrex 3X or 4 because those are testing for all the peptides of gluten and any other cross reactive foods because I would make people go gluten and dairy free regardless.
There's a lot of decrease in inflammation in your body and you have inflammatory response like, you know, especially some early dementia Parkinson's or arthritis or the inflammatory bowel disease, you have inflammation went out of your body, you got to decrease that inflammation and you have to look at food peptides.
And secondly, the Syrex 10 gives you 180 other foods, so that's what I would use the Syrex 10 all the time, that's the array 10 that measures all the other foods because you're already going to be very free. Well, we want to see any other cross reactive are the highlighted genes on by summary the ones that are defective or are all the genes listed in the summary defective.
All of your highlighted ones. Now, you have defects. I've never seen anybody, you know, there's never been in the history of creation, except for Adam and even, they have no defects in their genes. So environmental factors cause defects.
But I'll guarantee you, if you had the ability to measure your grandma and grandpa's tired, Gito, they would probably have a tenth of the maybe your great grandpa, maybe a tenth of the genetic defects that you do because our environment has been even greater poisoning that has affected our Gito in the last 40 years.
So you, so when I highlight or add highlights, one of us who are do whoever's doing them, the genes that we want you to take interested, those are the ones where you have the greatest amount of defects that or defects uncertain ones in the family that are more important that have been researched, and those are the ones you need to pay attention to just the highlighted ones, not the other ones.
So just look at the highlighted ones. I don't, we don't delete all the other ones because you want to read them on, you know, so it's just the highlight.
Remember those who have their genetics back already have three access to what are read your genes course, where you're going to let through of information for your genes, more than you've ever wanted to know when we keep adding to that.
On a weekly basis, so go to that course and read more information plus go to the frequency healing course. If you want more information on the right, this is the most that stuff is in
On the right page on that other side. All right, any other questions. I received only the T.S. gene sheet without the two. Yeah, I'm sorry.
Sometimes the report doesn't attach. So I'm going to make a note to you and send you the 200 page plus page report because
I catch it and it doesn't always go says that it's attached, but then when I say that you know it goes to never, never land because it's too big. So I have to set it separate.
You did get the 200 page.
Oh, so yes, let me, let me make sure that you got your summary. Okay.
So there's an action steps and there's a summary.
The petty plus it depends on when you receive that. So I'll have to look at you if you got everything that you know, I think it had it in one
Docuited before and then she separated about that. So I think she can. So I think you actually got it. She actually now separated them to documents.
All right, our verse for the day is a reminder for the message of the cross is foolishness to those who are perishing, but to those who are being saved. It's the power of God.
What's the message of the cross?
Well, first of all, it's a message of Jesus Christ dying for us. So we might have life access to life.
If we receive him, we'll die to ourselves. That's the other side of the cross. It's a reading to pick up our costs and carry the family to.
So that is the power of God who entrusted his power over everything that ours.
All right, well, thanks, everybody. I will get this up as soon as possible. And you're ever to send your messages on the member site.
I will be doing Monday's Zoom call as well for a while. And if you were not on Monday's call, I get a share of news about air. The reason why she's not doing Monday's call right now. It's her son was just recently diagnosed with
leukemia. So he was diagnosed with acute myeloid leukemia. He's 19 years old.
It just came on like literally over the night. He started feeling nausea and was thinking that it was his life.
He has chronic liability. It's there up about five years ago. She was thinking that's what it was.
All the signs pointed to that because it was just fatigue. He just wasn't feeling well.
But he just kept going down. He'll really quick. They had to break it into the ER.
And his pavement cloud was down to zero. But he really really well. And he just continued to crash.
But they got diagnosed with this chip literally. It was the first section of like
this explanation took place within a week. He just he was fine. He just crashed like that.
That's not uncommon with leukemias in young adults and children. And he was diagnosed with acute myeloid leukemia.
He was in the hospital right now doing chemotherapy because he literally could not get out of bed.
Here's this super muscular 19 year old athlete.
So it just be prayed for her and him his name is AJ.
Praise for him and for her family. She wanted me to tell you this. She said, I want you to tell this
to everybody. So people are praying for him. And then all our patients can know that we're all in this
together. So we all experienced what you guys are going through. And we want to know
you guys to know that we're praying for you. Tell us the name. We love you all.
So please be praying for anybody who's gone as well as praying for everybody to yourself.
All right. We will see you on Monday. Bye.